you were
actually training before yeah for a
while yeah
but you know what I just had I just had
a discussion with Bob okay
um what was the advice well it was I was
I'm prepared I wasn't really trying to
talk to him yeah but um it was just he
was just giving me punch from what the
church father said about Jesus Christ
like the Bible gives you criteria say
you tell you follow this church orders
and usually the other ones
but you can bring some checks for this
which they have support but I guess it's
Millions
even leave Victoria was corrupted
was there
they recorded
he was writing a response to a Jewish
rabbi
appearance that the rise of the New
Testament they were caught in the old
something in the Old Testament but it's
not dead
is not there so so the response that the
the Christian father or the Church
Father responded by saying but the
description
that's why you can't find it
I'm I'm sorry I'm really happy happy
we're not happy but but I do acknowledge
that that the tour and the gospel number
you don't have to go outside from within
you can see Jeremiah what does he say
hey yeah I know yeah he said how can we
trust the right
you know and also the generation that
were passing down to us the Torah same
generation that God is cursed in the Old
Testament
well I don't even believe the way that
the Old Testament makes gone out to me
and I think the old testamentally a
monster
you know
it's not just Gods though you know even
the prophet of God
you know like my teacher said before you
can see the rights of the Old Testament
they had to Grudge and get scored and
his messages
[Laughter]
he was a pure man he was a prophet of
God but in the Old Testament they
portrayed him as a liar who is that hit
them
you know I never heard Hitler got his
Soldier and set it up to be killed for
the sick sleep with his wife but David
did that we don't believe that we
believe the prophets of God didn't even
not didn't even judge it for him rebuke
him nothing yeah yeah yeah even he was
lying oh no he passed in something but I
want to tell us to do with the father
for them it was a salary but in the
tournament
he can see that
writers they are the people hatred and
that the prophet is good but we need to
talk
that story about Aaron Aaron and help in
the Jews to create an idol yeah I think
I read that he kind of like kind of
interesting
yeah yeah and then afterwards he turned
around and said well I didn't
like look that's what I'm saying bro
when you look for the extended teaching
how the prophets and Messengers Allah
portrayed them because why if I'm gonna
choose someone to teach you or teach
your family I'm going to choose the best
person someone trustworthy and honest
I'm not gonna treat someone else
would get the Israelites to make it to
make a golden car no no don't talk about
that he's the promise of God how are we
gonna make them right he came to teach
them how to for support you know and
even about what I call it a killing the
babies and children for something after
five minutes years ago that doesn't make
sense as well
they were people that believed in the uh
in Divine knowledge okay
um and uh they this is why they say how
success is a lot of the Old Testament
people was a faithful yeah
[Laughter]
Jacob who was a patient person
and the Satan but people start saying
the reason Jacob is grateful because why
because he has many blessings that's
what Allah puts it into test to show
people his grace for all the time but in
the Old Testament
to God the reason Jacob is grateful
because you don't test him so he says
say it's inspired or influence God to
test Jacob
if you know that it's corrupted while
you see a Christian should become a
Muslim worship God Alone the Quran is
perfect that's why I follow their seats
you follow me
same people yeah yeah but you still like
on a book that's corrupted
well I I don't I don't read I don't
really I don't really I don't read some
of the Gospel but I don't really read it
much anymore but what I'll ask you do
you feel the most wise God the most just
God would leave us with the corrupted
book or he will clarify the truth to us
God is the most wise thank you
okay see he's boosted everywhere it's a
more just intellectually it's illusion
but irrational impossible the most white
body would leave us with the corrupt
teaching they will clarify the truth as
you saw if you have if you if you have
if you write a book then people start
lying against you and attach you between
something to you you'll come out and
clarify yourself what about the most
high
when you want good for his creation
that's why Prophet Muhammad came and to
teach us the years there is Moses
Abraham Noah Jacob Isaac however the the
vakers the light against them you know
yes
I'm not in need of manuscripts you know
subhanallah
you know one thing is
people there
those Jewish people believe Prophet
Muhammad to be what
the belief Jesus to be a liar not a
messiah
fake Prophet what he would have done he
would have agreed with them to gain more
followers
[Music]
are you following me yeah yes because
why the Arab pagans they used to look up
to the Jewish people they are the people
of scripture
he went and cast them by defending Jesus
in Medina who they were no Christians in
Medina so there was no any gain for him
like from the material to defend Jesus
rather by defending Jesus he's going to
create another enemy which people yeah
it's going to increase his enemies so
what he did he defend Jesus because why
that shows you the Quran he was not from
Prophet Muhammad Allah told him to
defend Jesus because the message of
Allah regardless if there's Christians
or not you defend him because it is a
life against him that shows you this man
he was upon his man that's what the
nature and the characteristic of a liar
a liar will try to do anything to gain
more followers
changes you know so subham Allah is
crazy look how he's defending Jesus
there who I guess Jewish people I got a
question for you yes do you believe that
God because I've got mixed responses
from Muslims yeah do you believe God
doesn't love the disability no no just
non-believers
however Allah is merciful to them
because Allah is very special
yes Allah Allah loves goodness for these
Believers not for these Believers for
everyone but that's Allah love these
believers who they do in disbelief Lord
doesn't love them Allah
and if these Believers I'm not happy
they'll become a Muslim for Allah to
love you and you become happy there we
go simple because what Allah hates
Believers but I love good for them and
is still merciful to them and still be
good to them because Allah's love is
special
correct the love God is special
but I think that love is for everybody
okay
commits murder and rape children and I
say by doing this I'm gaining God's love
can I do that you can't do anything or
not do anything
that's constriction
What is love
it's very difficult of course what is
the love love okay if I said to you
someone that you love so much
I don't know someone he loves you you
feel very special because love is a
special thing
but if that's why if you want to get
Allah's love you follow his teaching but
if you commit a mistake Allah maybe you
hate that mistake as I'm still a
Believer but those disbelievers they are
Allah hate these Believers and doesn't
know how to put their skin color or
because their height because they choose
to follow Satan if they really love God
what they have to do
follow him because you know what I was
gonna said he said everyone claims to
love God everyone claims to us to love
God but the biggest question is it does
both love you
for me I know Allah
love you he will never punished in the
Hellfire eternally forever and he's not
going to all right so what happened to
pharaoh
he's not nobody's going to be punished
forever in their health no no would he
punish you for a long time
[Music]
I believe in reincarnation
doesn't make any sense okay if you
believe in our recommendation the first
person is Adam yeah yeah so with Adam
died
you know
I'm I'm the first person up on the earth
yeah if I die recognition make me feel
good another human being but there's
another human being
there was no one else
you never know you might have been being
mean
[Laughter]
tourism
snap in the in the life and Islamic
submission to God because you know we
can stand here try to justify our
disbelief or whatever but we're gonna
die and stand before the almighty
Creator and the almighty is the most
wise the most wise will never leave us
with the correct teaching for any
Clarity they will transfer the truth to
us
you don't lose no Jesus you love Jesus
Moses Abraham rather you believe in
Jesus and Moses the way they want you to
God wants you to believe in them
no the way the scribes of the Old
Testament the Liars haters portray them
to be
you see because you know you agree with
me you can see the rights of the Old
Testament they had a deep gradual hatred
and guess who and his messages
there are many things like about him his
property messages
you know even these disbelievers they
reject Allah but Allah still show the
mercy
feed them provide for them
and actually the mercy of Allah and even
that even that disbelievers Allah said
to be just with them
for justification for us to oppress
these Believers or not against them
because they are disbelievers look Allah
I don't know how we Define love love to
me is special for Mercy if someone rape
you to stand your mother would you love
him
I would at the time I probably want to
kill it
would you love him
love in that situation
love would be that situation in that
situation it would be to beat the
happens
and then and then and then call the
police
I love you so much
there's nowhere outside you go to them
you know what love is love is to put
someone in prison can I say no no no
this is
rapist
you know what I would because I know
even though I'll probably beat the
out of them and pull the police on them
I would still deep down know that that
person
deep down in who they really really are
would never do that but I did it yeah
what if he turns around I said I work
for the devil
because because the reason why people do
what they do is because they're living
in England yeah yeah okay no so he was
ignorant that raping a woman is as well
yes but no love him
you understand we're going to love
everybody
yeah the same way he loves this person I
love what you love Hitler the same way
you love Jesus the Jewish person who's
killed by the Hitler yeah but I take
care of yourself